square-enix presents an avalanche
Studios production Just Cause 3
Just Cause 3 is a huge open world game
with over 400 square miles of complete
freedom from sky to see that with a
large arsenal of weaponry gadgets and
vehicles prepare to unleash chaos in the
most creative and explosive ways you can
imagine Rico Rodriguez returns to his
mother's homeland the beautiful
Mediterranean island of Medici to
liberate it from the brutal dictatorship
of general Diavolo
obsessed with power D Ravello rules
Medici with an iron grip suppressing his
citizens building huge military
structures and leading a strong defense
force
but why does this island Republic need
such a large military the Rabello has
his eyes on much bigger things than just
Medici he sees global domination as his
ultimate conquest
Rico driven by the desire to return
Medici to its once beautiful and
peaceful past goes about bringing down
the revellers armies and military bases
by any means possible
Rico's tools of the trade include an
updated grappler which can be used
anywhere in the world to scale great
heights as a weapon of our moments of
Awesome stunt action now players can
deploy multiple grapple tethers enabling
Rico to chain together incredible
moments of chaos and destruction
combined with a new manual retract
function the grapple becomes even more
powerful and versatile slingshot
vehicles into checkpoints attached
soldiers to exploding fuel tanks smash
helicopters into the ground you can also
hook under objects and tear them apart
and even construct wrecking balls the
possibilities are endless
the parachute is now a far more stable
platform for combat helping Rico strike
his enemies with great precision using
one or two-handed weapons this allows
the combination between the grapple and
parachute to be a highly effective
combat force something that no other
game can do
on top of this there's the all-new
wingsuit which allows for total freedom
of the skies and completes Rico's aerial
abilities
Rico also carries a gun rack of machine
guns rifles handguns grenades rocket
launchers and unlimited c4 creating
spectacular kills and awesome explosions
Medici is filled with over 80 land sea
and air vehicles from sports cars to jet
planes via monster trucks and tractors
each one modeled in incredible detail
vehicles are a complex set of hinged
parts crumple zones and explosive fuel
tanks
buildings bases and gas stations all
blow up in unique physics-based chains
of destruction for amazing moments of
unpredictable chaos
all this comes together and just cause
three's incredible missions where you
tear down the generals bases of power
liberate towns in the open world and
gain access to new vehicles weapons and
rebel facilities as you progress d
Ravello knows where you are and he send
in a big ol army to kill you
additionally the world is packed full of
collectables and challenges to discover
all of which are tracked online for
high-score bragging rights
these include races scrapyard scrambles
classic gun ranges wingsuit courses
crash the bomb and destruction frenzies
complete them to unlock new mods that
upgrade Rico's explosive capabilities
and vehicles
giving players endless ways to cause
epic action destruction and chaos across
400 square miles of beautiful
Mediterranean paradise Just Cause 3
revolutionizes the open world genre one
massive explosion at a time
Square Enix and Avalanche Studios will
set the world on fire December 1st
[Applause]